Tach zusammen! Jack Pop hier.
Ich bin heute unterwegs und zwar in Jena
und treffe hier gleich meinen Freund Henry.
Der ist Physiker hier an der Hochschule
und er hat ein recht nerdiges Spezialthema nämlich
Superhelden.
Das passt super, denn Ihr habt uns ja schon
ganz häufig gefragt, was wäre, wenn Superhelden
echt sind?
Da spielen wir heute durch und wir starten
mit dem Videospiel Held überhaupt.
Hi Henry – hi Jack!
Schön, dass wir heute hier sein können.
Das ist deine Konsole?
Genau - die ist von mir zuhause. Ich habe
als Kind ziemlich viel Zeit Super Nintendo-Labor
verbracht und habe da ziemlich oft gezockt.
Was ich mich, beim Super Mario World spielen,
immer gefragt habe: Wo ist denn das eigentlich?
Ist das irgendwo hier auf der Erde versteckt
oder ist das in einem Paralleluniversum oder
auf einem anderen Planeten?
Du kannst uns heute helfen das herauszufinden.
Genau. Wir finden es einfach raus indem wir zocken.
Es ist ja ein klassisches Jump and Run-Game.
Es wird viel gesprungen und über den Sprung
können wir es rausfinden.
Wir müssen dafür rauskriegen wie hoch Mario
springt und wie lang braucht er dafür.
Als Messgerät können wir zum Beispiel Super
Mario direkt benutzen…
… Was machen wir da? Ein Maßband nehmen
funktioniert jetzt nicht so ganz aber wir
können unseren besten Kumpel Wikipedia fragen.
Der weiß es nämlich: Super Mario ist 1,50m groß.
Du hast tatsächlich am Bildschirm nachgemessen
wie oft er übereinander passt bis zu seiner
höchsten Sprungmarke.
Er passt nämlich genau viermal in seine eigene
Sprunghöhe rein.
Okay, vier mal 1,50m… Sechs Meter quasi.
Brauchen wir noch die Zeit – Du sahst auch
mit der Stoppuhr da – und für den ganzen
Sprung braucht er etwa 0,6 Sekunden.
Dann brauchen wir jetzt eine Formel, setzen
das ein und dann kriegen wir es raus.
Eine Formel eine klassische Formel aus der
Schule.
Die Formel für die Sprunghöhe ist ½ g mal
t2 + Anfangsgeschwindigkeit mal t + die Anfangshöhe.
Also erstmal machen wir die Formel ein bisschen
einfacher.
Auch wir Physiker mögen komplizierte Formeln
nicht unbedingt.
Wenn Mario nach oben springt würde abgebremst,
kommt kurz zur Ruhe und fällt wieder nach
unten. Wir betrachten nur die zweite Hälfte
der Bewegung wenn er aus der Ruhe los fällt.
Das bedeutet die Anfangsgeschwindigkeit seine
Bewegung ist in diesem Punkt null;
also fällt das schon mal weg.
Und die Anfangshöhe –jetzt könnte ich
was über Koordinatensysteme und so weiter
erzählen – aber ich bin auch Physiker und
wir machen die Naturgesetze deswegen streichen
wir das auch einfach weg.
Und was wir ja wissen wollen ist, wie groß
g eigentlich ist.
Das heißt wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Mathematik,
stellen das Ganze um und dann kommt raus,
dass g gleich 2 mal h geteilt durch t2 ist.
Und tatsächlich: Wir brauchen nur die Höhe
und die Zeit.
Wow - sieht gut aus. Dann setzen wir jetzt
unsere Werte ein, denn die haben wir ja schon
und dann kriegen wir das raus.
Das heißt das g auf Super Mario World ist
2 mal 6m geteilt durch die Zeit, das ist jetzt
nur noch die halbe Zeit, also machen wir 0,3
Sekunden ins Quadrat.
Wenn wir das ausrechnen kommt heraus, dass
das 133 Meter pro Quadratsekunde sind.
g auf Super Mario World ist ungefähr 13 mal
das g auf der Erde.
Das heißt auf der Erde kann's nicht sein.
Wir müssen uns ein bisschen umgucken.
Vielleicht auf einem anderen Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem?
Wir können uns zum Beispiel die erdähnlichen Planeten angucken. Der mit dem größten g-Wert ist die Venus,
die hat ungefähr 0,9 g.
Wir brauchen mehr Masse, oder? Genau wir brauchen
mehr Masse und da gucken wir uns einfach den
massereichen Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem an.
Das ist der Jupiter aber der kommt auch nur auf 2,5 g.
Wenn wir noch mehr Masse nehmen hätten wir
nun die Sonne die hat wahrscheinlich…
… 28 g – also sehr sehr viel und sie ist
sehr sehr heiß. Also Mario würde verdampfen
wenn er da umspringen würde.
Dann könnten wir noch gucken, ob es irgendwo
einen Exoplaneten gibt.
Genau. Es gibt also eine Datenbank, da kann
man reingucken und da sind die g-Werte für
die verschiedenen Planeten gelistet.
Es gibt tatsächlich Planeten die sehr viel
mehr g haben als unsere Sonne, zum Beispiel
der Planet Corot-3b, der hat 55 g.
Aber ich habe keinen Planeten gefunden, der
diese 13 g hatte.
Das heißt Glück für Euch! Denn wenn Ihr
Physik studiert und in die Astrophysik geht,
dann könnt ihr den Planeten selbst noch finden
und seid dann quasi die Entdecker von
Super Mario-World.
Das klingt doch schon mal ziemlich fancy.
Das klingt ziemlich cool. Wenn man den dann
auch Super Mario-World nennt. Perfekt.
Okay jetzt haben wir das Problem 13 g ist
ja schon eine Menge. Wie kriegt Mario das
hin; also diese Anziehungskraft zu überwinden?
Das ist eine gute Frage, denn dies g beschreibt
wie schwer Dinge sind.
Das heißt Mario ist 13 mal schwerer,
als auf der Erde wäre und auf der Erde sechs
Meter hoch springen ist schon ziemlich sportlich.
Das heißt Mario müsste ziemlich kräftige
Beine haben und ziemlich muskulös sein.
Er müsste auch 13 mal schweres Blut in seinen
Kopf pumpen.
Das heißt er braucht auch ein ziemlich kräftiges
Herz. Das heißt Mario wäre also ein ziemlich
großer Herzmuskel mit kräftigen Beinen.
Und Augen und einer Mütze.
Das ist schon mal ziemlich spannend. Dann
gibt's da noch diese Pilze die Mario isst.
Bei denen wird er größer, das heißt er
wächst ja nochmal.
Hat er dann noch mehr Probleme mit der Schwerkraft?
Wie würde das überhaupt funktionieren mit
diesen Pilzen? Geht das?
Naja er bräuchte einen ziemlich guten Stoffwechsel.
Das heißt wenn der Pilz kommt da, der hat
ja ungefähr sein Volumen, dann verstoffwechselt
er sofort diesen Pilz und wird doppelt so
groß.
Vielleicht geht das bei einem Außerirdischen…
man weiß es ja nicht.
Aber das Problem ist, wenn er dann von dem
Gegner getroffen wird, dann wird er ziemlich
schnell kleiner.
Man muss sich überlegen, wie das funktioniert,
dass er innerhalb von kürzester Zeit ziemlich
viel Volumen verliert.
Da muss ich sagen: wahrscheinlich gibt er
ziemlich schnell ziemlich viel Gas ab.
Mario furzt sich klein?
Könnte man so sagen und dabei tritt folgendes
Problem auf: Wenn Gase sich sehr schnell ausdehnen
dann werden sie sehr kalt.
Das heißt Mario würde wahrscheinlich einfrieren.
Der Effekt, der dabei eine Rolle spielt,
ist der Joule-Thompson-Effekt.
Da dehnt sich das Gas auch sehr schnell aus
und verrichtet dabei eben Arbeit, es müssen
die Anziehungskräfte zwischen den Teilchen
überwunden werden, das kostet Energie und
die Energie kommt eben aus der Bewegungsenergie
und weniger Bewegungsenergie bedeutet kleinere
Temperaturen.
Wir haben das jetzt alles durchgesprochen
aber wir können den Joule-Thompson-Effekt
auch zeigen. Und zwar haben wir euch hier
ein schönen C02 Feuerlöscher mitgebracht.
Genau das ist die Situation wie Super Mario.
Das Ding ist ja auch schon so rot wie sein Pulli.
Und da drin steht das Gas jetzt unter sehr sehr hohem Druck. So wie das in Super Mario drin
auch unter einem ganz hohen Druck stehen würde.
Ganz genau.
Das heißt wir gucken jetzt was passiert wenn
wir das Gas hier raus lassen (das Kohlendioxid)
und wir fangen das mit so einem Beutel auf.
Henry ich zähl von drei runter.
3… 2… 1… und los!
Irre!
Hier sieht man schon, dass es mega kalt ist,
man kann es kaum anfassen.
Hier ist Trockeneis draus geworden. Das ist
der feste Zustand von Kohlendioxid.
Das sind minus 78 Grad Celsius
Das wird jetzt hier unter Raumtemperatur schon
wieder gasförmig.
Also Ihr seht, Gase werden beim Ausdehnen
im schlimmsten Fall extrem kalt.
Wir fassen also zusammen.
Super Mario-World hat die 13 fache Erdanziehungskraft,
liegt auf keinem uns bekannten Planeten, Mario
müsste ein einziger großer Herzmuskel sein
und er würde beim Furzen einfrieren.
Ganz genau.
Physik ist gar nicht so langweilig wie man oft denkt.
Henry hat noch ein paar andere Superhelden
auf Lager und die Videos veröffentlichen
wir nach und nach hier auf dem Kanal.
Vielleicht habt ihr aber auch ganz eigene
Ideen für Superhelden, die wir mal durchspielen sollen.
Dann bitte schreibt es uns in die
Kommentare; auch wie ihr diese kleine Nerd-Runde hier fandet.
Ich sag erstmal Tschüss und
bis nächsten Mittwoch.